what's going on there reject nation greg
and john here today
so apparently uh total film magazine
had some special marvel thingy going on
the whole thing was done in conjunction
with marvel i don't really know the
details about it
i'm supposed to leave tanner in a few
hours right now uh just gonna be gone
for a couple of days but
of course you know we've uploaded like
nine videos in a row that we're not
cosmic wonder videos and all we do is
cover cosmic wonder according to some
people
so we have to cover this before i leave
town and that is
spider-man no way home preview breakdown
and big
trailer news uh also guys uh last night
we were at a screening for a quiet place
part two
uh where john krasinski and jj abrams
were both there
and so yeah we're gonna share with you
guys a review that we did in the movie
right out of the theater later on today
and then uh
also probably share a little clip from
when
jj abrams read our question and john
krasinski answered the
question and no it had nothing to do
with fantastic four anyway let's go into
it
what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
things
are really starting to heat up for
spider-man no way
home the trailer for the film is right
around the corner
today we have more news and proof that
the trailer is about to drop and if
you've been following my videos lately
you know that total film magazine today
released what they called a preview for
upcoming marvel films
this issue of total film magazine is
primarily about
loki which is about to come out on
disney plus unless yeah
yeah yeah yeah but in the article they
included some tidbits
about other marvel phase four films that
are coming up pretty soon
spider-man no way home was one of them
side note thor love and thunder was also
one of them and apparently they're not
going to be doing the space sharks
anymore which is a pretty big bummer
tiger with tt said that there was a
legal issue so they could no longer use
them
a legal issue for 14
different upcoming mcu projects pretty
much the entire phase four slate
in this issue of total film magazine
at
left in my stormbreaker giveaway to
enter just subscribe to my channel and
cosmic culture will be picking a winner
on monday
so as far as spider-man no way home is
concerned we got
kind of a lot but also kind of a little
total film magazine
advertised on the very cover of their
issue a preview for
upcoming marvel projects spider-man no
way home was one of them and their
preview is basically a little synopsis
of the film
and the synopsis is actually kind of
weird and i'll explain what i mean
but first let's go over it it says
spider-man
no way home director john watts starring
tom holland zendaya jamie foxx
eta estimated time of arrival 17th of
december
2021 and it says after a lot of legal
wrestling
what the hell what a weird start back in
the mcu
third solo past life that is
electro jamie foxx and doctor past
life are rumored to return to a bigger
broader spider verse that's now reeling
from peter parker's recent unmasking
so this kind of just makes me laugh
because at this point
this is the worst kept secret in
hollywood this
issue of total film magazine is a
partnership between total film and
marvel
disney they literally work together on
this
so the fact that they're trying to stay
straight rumored
that electro and doctor octopus are
going to show up is
pretty hilarious because we know that
all they're trying to do
is make people second guess that maybe
they won't be in the film but
we know they are at this point because
both actors have confirmed this
you make a solid solid point there the
fact that marvel worked with this is in
agreeance
in accordance with marvel so for them to
to like agree to this like a log line
essentially
for what they can tease it's like why
why even mention it
it's like going also rumored daredevil
supposed to be in it kirsten dunst is
rumored to be in it you're you're
specifically citing these people and
saying
uh and rumored to return to a bigger
broader spider-verse
marvel themselves is eluding and hinting
at spider-verse
they're they're the ones getting in
there and saying it and also
i'm kind of confused by the whole thing
with past life
baddies i mean that could just be
reading
way too much into it like the spider-man
of the past
that's probably just what it means but
when you say past life baddies
that sounds like these are baddies from
tom holland's past and when that's not
the case
so yeah it's it's a weird plot synopsis
maybe it's suggesting that in
past lives tom holland was andrew
garfield and toby maguire
is that are you being serious yeah how
does that work
it doesn't but i'm saying like that's
the what the language implies to me and
also
yeah that's what i mean by that this is
like strangely written yeah yeah and
might also
bring up the legal stuff
i'm like are they going to make this
meta where it's like oh daredevil shows
up
to to figure out the sony disney
contract so that the movie can happen
it's weird to include in your plot
synopsis
that you have worked in conjunction with
with marvel agreeance
rumors if they are only rumors it's a
weird thing very strange very
dr strange this is literally marvel
saying
don't say too much about the film don't
confirm the spider-verse we're not going
to do that yet
but try to get people excited so mention
the spider-verse but also say that it's
a rumor at this point
but honestly what's really the point now
i mean we know at this point in time
that it's going to be a spider-verse
film we know alfred molina is coming
back and we know jamie foxx is coming
back
but i commend them to sticking to it and
not really admitting it until the
trailer comes out
now the part at the end that is rather
interesting says these characters are
rumored to return to a bigger
broader spider-verse that's now reeling
from peter parker's recent unmasking
this almost makes it sound like the
spider-verse is being caused
by the fact that peter parker's identity
has been revealed and we know that
that's not the case
the multiverse isn't going to burst open
just because peter parker's identity has
been revealed or maybe it could maybe
they could make some type of weird
storyline out of it but we know that's
not how it's going to be
we know that loki is going to cause some
pretty big issues for the multiverse we
know that the snap
probably caused some big issues as well
and wanda probably is going to play some
part
instead what i think they're saying here
in this description is that these
characters are going to be a part of a
now bigger spider-verse and they're
going to find themselves in the
mcu and the mcu right now is kind of in
chaos
and the fact that peter parker's
identity has been revealed makes it a
little bit more chaotic especially since
we have
previous spider-man villains returning
who will most likely try to fight
spider-man and now they know who he is
and this is what they had to say for
their so-called
preview which really wasn't that much of
a preview
so it's kind of weird that they
advertised it as such but it's not
really
the cell magazine overwhelmed with
spiderman no way home info
but at the same time this just further
confirms the multiverse again they're
talking about all these
rumors but this was a collaboration with
marvel and disney
so if martin knows they had to approve
it
hey it's rumored that the spider verse
is coming and these characters are going
to be in the film
then they tell them not to say that it's
like at this point marvel why not just
say it especially if you're going to do
this big cover issue
and work with total film magazine and
let that be
part of your plot synopsis like just
let's confirm it nah nah let us let us
languish
let us twist out here trying to figure
it out and just have fun watching us
squirm
we already alfred molina has already did
a big interview jb fox sucked at hiding
it like this
it's so obvious at this point it's past
the point of rumor that's the thing
it's it's already confirmed that's the
ridiculous part about it it's
already confirmed here's my point even
if the
other spider-man are not in it it's
still a spider-verse movie
because you already confirmed alfred
molina and jamie foxxer
so it's already a spider-verse movie
those are from two different spider-man
franchises
and i love it so if marvel and or disney
did not want them to say
hey it's rumored that the spider-verse
is coming and these characters are going
to be in the film
then they tell them not to say that now
they are journalists and they are an
outlet so they could kind of write
whatever they wanted to but again since
they're kind of partnered with sony and
disney on this
you wouldn't want to upset them in any
way because then that relationship is
done
then the magazine would get no more
actor interviews or any information at
all from marvel
they're fired about their upcoming films
so this is total film is a menace
what marvel and disney want it to be in
line with they gave them the okay to say
the spider-verse is rumored and to me it
just seems like they're just waiting for
the trailer to confirm
the spider verse which makes sense they
want to be the ones who
break the news and speaking of it's
already broken like i said we do
already broke today and it's good news
and it looks like the trailer
is happening soon i don't want to get
people's hopes up too much in case it
doesn't happen but
that june release date for the trailer
is looking pretty good right now
six months before the release that makes
sense sony pictures
germany account had changed their
background banner to the spider-man no
way home logo
and their official twitter account did
the same and now we have
even more sony youtube accounts changing
their banners to spider-man no way home
the banner has been changed on sony
pictures austria
sony pictures of vietnam and sony
pictures cambodia and this is big news
because this means that they are
preparing for the trailer to drop
they're preparing for the promotion of
the film to begin which starts with the
trailer
i've said this a couple of times but for
those of you who may not have heard it
you really don't start promotion on a
film unless a
teaser trailer at least has been
released because the general population
won't know
anything about the film and it's really
hard to promote merchandise like shirts
and toys
unless there's already some type of
preview for the movie out there
otherwise people just really won't know
so this is a great sign that the trailer
is indeed about to drop
and a lot of people are looking at that
june 1st release date because it's tom
holland's birthday and considering the
fact that it looks like that's right
they did that for
me ramp up for spiderman no way home
that is definitely a possibility
but it is not confirmed so i would say
don't expect it on june 1st but if it
happens
awesome now spider-man no way home isn't
the only synopsis that we got
the main article was obviously about
loki but they actually gave us a little
synopsis about all of the upcoming
marvel phase 4
projects now this is a spider-man video
so i'll keep it about spider-man but
tomorrow i'll do a full
breakdown of what each synopsis says
about for all of these films including
thor love and thunder
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness the marvels
black panther wakanda forever the
fantastic fantastic versus
emily blunt and who wrote that look at
the fantastic four
emily blunt and john krasinski as sue
storm and reed richards
do they really work with marvel i don't
feel like this is real
i think maybe marvel is entering a
mimichero where they're like let's just
mess with
everyone's fan expectations and we'll
not confirm them but we'll poke them and
we'll get everyone riled up with this
piece that's not
actually that in-depth you know
yeah i've even like freaking we're
looking at guardians of the galaxy
stalled and then resurrected again
they're just acknowledging all the
behind the scenes drama of things too
that's so strange this is though this is
so
weird i kind of love it i kind of love
it it's pretty cool thor love and
thunder
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness the marvels
black panther wakanda forever the
fantastic four
ant-man and the wasp quantum mania
guardians of the galaxy
vol 3 and those are all the movies and
then of course they have the disney plus
shows coming up
hawkeye miss marvel moon knight
she-hulk the guardians of the galaxy
holiday special which they now have
listed as an eta for december 2022
and secret invasion which is also listed
for 2022 as well
and also says that it is starring amelia
clark
and for those happy gilmore fans out
there yesterday it was announced that
christopher
mcdonald the actor that played shooter
mcgavin is joining
secret invasion as well so after a
pretty dark let's say a year and a half
of covet 19 and marvel kind of put on
hold it seems like everything is rolling
full
force right now it doesn't look like
we're going to be having any more delays
knock on wood and it looks like the
trailers for these films and
shows coming out on disney plus are just
going to start rolling out and the next
one on the list is spider-man
no way home and look out for that in the
next few weeks i'll
update you if i hear anything else about
when the trailer could drop
in the meantime don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification you
better text me when you know
all of the latest mcu news don't forget
the link i've given you a heads up about
a couple follow me on instagram and
twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching
and on the ones i've given you a heads
up about your videos of outperformed
arse so no more of that no more
now we're now dedicated to syncing your
channel
dick i'm gonna feed you a lot of bad
scoops
warren i've been really loving your
videos lately i think your energy
and enthusiasm is such a big part of
what gets me excited
i mean nothing beats talking with you on
the phone directly but when i
listen to your videos i'm like damn
i can't wait great job kudos to you and
uh yeah man thank you thank you for
keeping us updated guys subscribe to
cosmic wonder if you haven't done so
already
you bet your ass we will be on top of
that spider-man no way home
trailer and you bet your ass will
complain when they have some little
license song in there for five seconds
that gets our video demonetized
after waking up at five in the morning
to do our best work to cover it so
yeah and then we'll do a breakdown
coverage after that
you know you know how we do
hey hit that like button we'll catch you
guys soon